we thought that we understood when we
started this journey that
okay cars are very expensive let's
design a cheaper car
no and there are many many other
challenges in racing and we learn them
mainly by operating a racing series
[Music]
tamira placinski thank you for joining
me on 20 minute leaders
a good afternoon to both of us thank you
happy to be here
uh okay before we start i need you to
tell me about this background what am i
saying here
yeah it's cool huh what you say is the
different user interfaces
of our data platform uh which we call
ramp
a data platform developed for
motorsports
uh this is what grip is now involved in
focusing
focusing in and
wow different screens so in order for me
to even begin to try and understand what
i'm seeing here
um like i mentioned before we started i
don't know the difference between the
toyota
and the kia and the hyundai to me
they're all
bare metals on four wheels that get me
from point a to point b
but i really appreciate people that have
a passion for it so so tamir
tell me before we start talking about
racing cars
how do you get started with an industry
like this what type of upbringing do you
have where you get so passionate about
race cars
yeah so the key word here is uh exactly
what you said
it's passion and you cannot
describe or explain passion either you
have it or either you don't
uh a lot of people in the world
apparently have
this kind of passion for cars for
driving
for driving fast for the adrenaline for
the excitement
racing motorsport all those things uh
which uh exist
in motosport motorsport is like the the
sport for those who love
uh driving and cars and everything and
and
i think for me personally it's uh
something i have since i remember i can
remember since i was a little a little
boy
and uh growing up in israel uh being
passionate about motorsport is not a
very
nice thing to do because the israel
right
there is no motorsport or i was about to
ask right
i don't see you know i just came back
from dubai every
second street i go and there's a lineup
of ferraris and lamborghinis i remember
seeing
even a single lamborghini here in israel
yeah those uh
exotic sports cars are one thing but you
don't have any motorsport culture in
israel it's like you don't have rx or
racecar manufacturers or industry or
anything and like that
actually it was illegal until around
2015 so
in israel and you only see that in the
news in newspapers and on tv
but you don't really get to be involved
in such an activity
and that's something i've always wanted
to do so growing up
i had a dream to become a world champion
that was my dream uh
driving something moderate motorcycle
race car whatever but
you come to the understanding that when
you're 21 after uh you know
serving in the in the military it's a
bit late
to start your career
so i went to study mechanical
engineering in the university with the
dream to
get uh to be to become involved in the
industry i i described it to myself back
then as
be involved in the automotive industry
and i i
wanted to go to italy that was like a
country i saw as the best place to go
and
and do that uh ferrari or lamborghini
i i don't i didn't really care uh and
and then it became reality when uh
during my studies i started a formula
student team it's like a
team of students developing race cars
for a student competition you race
against other
universities wow i started the first
team in israel
uh back in 2010 and then we we went to
an event in italy we were the
team it was totally underground project
no one in the university really knew
knew what we were doing we tested the
car in abandoned
parking lots at night it was really
uh one day we'll do and we will make a
movie on that year
uh and then going to italy for the event
i bet uh the main sponsor of the
competition was a race car company from
italy
and they offered me a a job so
i i fulfilled my dream and i went to
work
in motorsport in race car manufacturer
the best one
uh in in the world called the lava
uh spent six months uh
living the dream completely as you can
imagine
and then coming back to israel i was so
hyped
about okay i know what i want to do i
love the i love racing i love race cars
let's do something in israel
uh in motorsport and i saw only
advantages in the fact that there is no
industry in israel
uh in in motorsport you can only uh
if you have no uh constraints you can do
whatever you want you know 100
right tamir i you know before we
continue i have to
get a little bit of a better
understanding about motorsports
the is as an industry even before we get
to to to what you're doing with the grip
because
to to an to an outsider it all i can
think about is that you know some places
there are
race cars there's these crazy people
that get into these crazy fast cars that
are driving around in circles
to to be the fastest time what is this
industry all about what is the
excitement
to give me some numbers who who is the
audience
and what does it take to get there i
really am curious about this
yeah that's a good question so uh
motorsport
is uh probably i
i i think i won't offend offend anyone
by saying that
it's the most complex port in the world
you don't only have the athlete you have
also the machine
and it's about the main machine
integration that eventually
and it's it's harder to understand as a
viewer as a fan
because it's not like you have a ball
you need to throw it you have a score
this is uh
they it's it's more complex you need to
understand why this driver is faster
than the other
uh what it there are a lot a lot of
things that you don't
uh catch with the untrained eye
and also you have let's say in a race 10
20 50 cars it doesn't matter the number
but as the number of cars
are the number of potential events
happening every second
on a football uh game or basketball you
have one ball
all the eyes are looking at that at that
ball and what happened with the ball is
the event going on
in a race you have a lot of cars
everyone can do something so you have
many balls
so it's much difficult to understand
uh but still uh watching cars going
fast on a track it's a very exciting
thing the the battle
you know that it's the risk factor back
then when it started
and make the sport much very much
like gave the interesting factor to it
right now they are risking their lives
and unfortunately unfortunately we can
still see
drivers uh getting hurt on the track
even though safety became
much much better than it was used to be
but
the combination of speed and risk and
sound and and
everything is like a spectacular like no
other sport
at least in my mind but being
that complex with the facilities and the
cars or motorcycles and everything it's
a very expensive sport
and that's like uh a big big negative
thing for the industry because
you always want to have as many drivers
and as many people participating but
there is the money barrier
in motorsport that you need to have a
lot of money money plays
a very big role in motorsports
right actually you actually surprised me
when i talked about the the human
machine integration that that is a key
to success you know i always imagined it
that
you know yeah you have the top players
the top athletes i didn't even think of
them as athletes i thought
okay they're really great you know
hand-eye coordination and then
whoever gets the best car wins but what
you're saying is that it actually
it's the combination of the car specs
and the drivers
you know specific skill sets that if
they're aligned that's what
is causing the special circumstance
right it's not just that if the
car is better than that they win
yeah yeah if you look at the different
racing racing series in the world that
that balance varies from let's say
formula one
uh when there are different
manufacturers and and
we look at formula one as a series where
the car
has more effect on the final result
result if you look look at lower uh
tiers series let's say even what we call
single maker series where
all the cars are are identical but you
can still
do different setups for the car so
that's where the driver's
talent right
that's that makes a lot of sense so i'm
looking at a dashboard and i
have no idea why we would need a
dashboard for a
motor racing industry tell me about this
of course i'm teasing when i say that i
that that a lot of the things that i
don't understand it's
it's too complicated for me to
understand but i wish i understood it
better
so um i think by the way this dashboard
as a
like a mirrored because i think i see
the english there
back up like i i'm i think i'm seeing it
okay
yeah so it's like uh i'm sitting behind
it i know it's something in the proper
way um i i will explain the dashboard by
continuing like this short history about
and so grip when i when i came back to
israel i started grip
as a brand to make motorsport more
accessible i
i just finished my last uh uh
explanation saying that
it's very expensive and that's where we
saw grip comes in
the market offering a different
something different
like we wanted to give more people
opportunity to participate
and we started maybe not in the most
common place to start
but we started with the driver and we
said okay let's give the driver
a better a better solution to race
a more cost effective solution so we
started by designing a race car
it's not a very simple thing to do for a
small startup
small startup from a country with no
motorsport with no racetracks
wow knowledge it was pretty
intense but you know you set up to do
something and you're very determined so
that's what you
what you do and we eventually we
designed a race car uh started the
racing series in italy that's the series
you see in the in the picture uh that's
like on board from that series
uh that was a single maker series only
for our cars
the car by the way is we call it the
model name is g1 and the series was the
g1
series it ran for two years and
during those two years uh we learned a
lot about motorsport we thought
that we understood when we started this
journey that
okay cars are very expensive let's
design a cheaper car
no there are many many other challenges
in racing and we learned them
mainly by operating a racing series and
we could
know that that before we started
uh this uh racing series you can imagine
an israeli manufacturer of course in
cars runs a series in north italy
it was it's not the most common thing
you'll
you'll hear by the way how does this
work so you you design the cars you
manufacture the cars and then you have
to go and pitch those cars
as a series to drivers to come and drive
them to compete
is that how it works yes some something
like that yeah you need to start
building your connections and
get to know more teams and more drivers
and convince them that your series have
a value for them because it has a lower
barrier for entry
and it's very fast the cars and you have
a lot of
exposure so people will see you if you
want to start your career and stuff like
that
but saying that that we were very
focused on the series when we started
back in 2018 but again we wanted to
we we were very we were still
but back then we were a very small uh
uh young tech company and we thought
okay
what else we can do to make our cars
better to
differentiate them them from other cars
and we wanted
uh to give the drivers the ability to
not
uh need to hire experts to help him
improve
because motorsport uh like it's very
data
uh centric sport you need to rely on
data to improve
it's not as simple as kicking a ball
into the
goal or something even in that area we
are starting to see more and more data
coming in right motorsport on the cars
you have a lot of sensors already and
you need to know how to use that data
to improve and drivers usually don't
know that you need to hire that expert
to do that
and we said okay we can
go around that expert and give the
driver
those uh tips of on how to improve
automatically if we make all the cars
connected
we upload the data we analyze the data
in real time and we give that
to the drivers and that's where we
started developing our data platform
again it was for the driver we had the
dream like you imagine you're driving
and you sing
like you hear what you need to improve
or you see that in on the dashboard or
something but the car teaches you that's
what we wanted to do
but then we started the series we
understood that this solution
is not limited only for the driver
because as a series you want to
also differentiate yourself you want to
attract viewers
that will bring sponsors that will bring
more drivers right
it's not easy so yeah exactly that
spiral you did the exact
motion that we are doing and uh
malcolm our uh evp of media solutions
will be super proud when you see
that because this is what you do that's
all the time anyway
uh so we understood that we have a
solution here
that no one has no one else developed
that yet
we looked for other solutions we
couldn't find anyone anything
and then we we thought okay that's what
we need to do we need to develop that
platform for
racing and this is where we like we saw
the light and
we didn't look back since and that's
what you're seeing
around uh like on my background
you see different user interfaces like
the data augmentation we do for the
linear tv broadcast
uh the overview screen that if you're a
driver you can go and see where you are
compared to other drivers uh
the briefing screens for the drivers to
see where they do what they did good or
bad
uh a second screen viewing uh
uh interface for the for the end users
for the viewers
and many more and that's what we are
doing now we are also implementing
the connectivity to esports which is
crazy thing because this is also
something unique for motosport in
in racing unlike other uh
sports the game that you play it's
similar completely to driving a car
except for the acceleration because you
sit at home with your steering wheel and
the pedals
you can buy a kit it's it doesn't it's
not expensive
but when you play nba 2002k or
fifa you don't have a basketball and a
hoop right no
no you cannot see yourself going on the
court with lebron james
starting to play against him but if you
are a super scene driver
actually you can go on track you need to
be fit
and and race with the best and you'll
see wow
unbelievable and i can already imagine
the virtual reality headsets that are
already placing you in there with
you know potentially vibrating chair and
that can you know
mimic the acceleration that's crazy yeah
so that's what we call mixed reality
races
and and this is something the platform
is is going to
also because it's a data platform
eventually
and we can collect data from cars we
collect
data from simulators it's the same thing
and we
merge them together wow that's just
unbelievable and so tell me about a
little bit about the future of of the
racing sport because cars are becoming
more autonomous
i'm watching you know the different cars
on the road like tesla
already you know advertising that they
go to zero to sixty in three seconds
is this gonna affect in any way um
racing
are we ever going to see autonomous cars
racing each other
you know potentially also against humans
so uh you'll be surprised but there is
there are already autonomous cars racing
each other
uh there's a series called the robber
race and they are
autonomous cars that are racing each
other it's pretty cool um
motorsport traditionally was there
acted as the development platform for
the automotive industry so you see a lot
of manufacturers
developing technologies on track
and then those technologies are being
conveyed to the road cars that you are
using
and we see that very strongly today with
the electric
revolution right those electric
components are being
uh taken to the limit on the track and
getting their
track tested that stamp and then you you
can use that
so motosport will play as i see it a
very significant role
in the years to come as that as again
the place where
all those new technologies will be
perfected uh
and also uh even when
uh in in whenever it comes and the roads
will be filled with autonomous cars and
you will not be allowed to drive
i think uh those islands uh
where you can uh experience that uh
human emotion that is one of the most
amazing you know if you can fly a jet
fighter maybe it can be more
exciting but taking a car on on track to
the limit is something that
it's it's crazy it's amazing experience
and i don't see that
disappear uh i hope never
i now i'm gonna have to go and try that
for myself because because yeah it
sounds exactly it sounds exhilarating
and you know being a little bit distance
from from the field you never actually
you know imagine yourself there but but
now i i can see why the excitement i can
see the thrill
and i can more than anything see the
potential of what you're doing here
a data driven platform for for motor
racing
both for the driver but also for the
game for the for the player at home for
the viewer on the tv
and for the team that is debriefing
after and also the manufacturer of the
car
that wants to see okay how did the
driver interact with the car what were
the limitations
how did we hold up again against others
i think that you're
exactly on to on to what it should be
and it's really really impressive thank
you
to me or for taking the time to share
this with me and before we
before we leave i have to ask you for
the hardest question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um i just wanted before i answer to say
that you describe it perfectly but
because what we are saying that we are
doing is uh creating a digital universe
around racing brands so that's
you described that universe it's not the
user so it's beautiful
uh very much three words um
determined i think
uh creative yeah
[Music]
um uh
optimistic energetic i don't know yeah i
think
the first two was were much easier uh
that's why it is that's why it's the
hardest question and then
and i'll take i'll take all those four
or five words all those things seem to
me yeah
i think the two the first two were the
strong like what i say
i think can describe myself the best 100
percent
you know the story of growing up in
israel with with practically no industry
but
yet you have the passion and motivation
to go there creating this grassroots
program within ben gurion university in
bercheva of a team that is going to race
with a car
in in italy going to land a job in italy
coming back starting a company
based in israel that creates a series in
italy i mean it's the whole stories of
determination and perseverance and
creativity
above it all so so thank you thank you
tamir again for the inspiration this was
wonderful
and stay safe and healthy yeah my
pleasure
and honor thank you